anytime I hear someone pushing for
socialized medicine I find myself
getting in touch with my inner Kevin
McCallister seeing as it was raised in
Canada I always get the same comments
from dumb liberal Americans I hear you
got great Medicare in Canada yeah you
know it's not that great not as good as
you think no man no man I read it I read
it article said you got a good health
care okay you want to know your health
care plan in Canada don't get sick
yes sickness is about the only thing we
don't cover let me run you through the
average blood test in Canada you have to
get up at odhh arc 30 head on down to
the local clinic grab a number wait two
three maybe five hours legally they're
technically not allowed to tell you how
long the way it's gonna be
sit there with all the coughing sneezing
lepers for all you know until finally
it's your turn and you get to a
disgruntled under-qualified governmental
employee shutting a piece of metal in
your arm fun for the whole family it's
like Russia without the Bears and
tricycles in America you pay money for
your drugs in Soviet Canada we have no
drugs people always complain about
health care in the US I don't see why I
should have to pay money for my drugs no
of course not because it's not like
drugs cost money to make they come from
a magical lollipop field a land where
Nancy Pelosi and Al Gore spin recycled
trash into golden yarn and insulin shots
here's the way I look at it if Richard
Simmons can make dozens of million
dollars from dance your pants off volume
for the guy who gave us the polio
vaccine deserves some loose change we
have to acknowledge that the vast
majority of new drugs come from private
companies who invest huge amounts and
take very large risks in order to turn a
profit and those drugs wouldn't cost so
much if the FDA stopped by linking their
progress there are dozens of possible
cures sitting on the FDA shelf for
countless diseases that we don't have
access to because they might cause
slight stomach discomfort what am i for
I can handle a stomachache is the
government gonna make us eat our dinner
slowly and wait an hour before swimming
too so
a little guys you can't kill yourself
because you might get a tummy ache oh
we're also banning milkshakes now
because they've been known to cause
brain freeze and Soviets Canada
milkshakes you
we need price cuts bro that's what we
need do you know what happened when
Canada implemented federal price cuts in
the late 1960s drug research dropped by
more than 50% considering that the
United States is a largest contributor
to drug research do you really think the
world can afford us going socialized you
want to know who's really pushed the
envelope the United States at
drastically reducing drug prices Walmart
I couldn't believe the list of $4
prescriptions available there it's like
a junkies dream and after Walmart did it
every local drug store chain jumped in
on the bandwagon ah capitalism in the
free market benefiting the lower middle
class again in America you buy your
groceries at Walmart in Soviet Canada we
have no holes a lot houses and it is
very cold
[Music]